significa esta ausencia que el
presidente de mexico se alinea al menos
con los
cuba de venezuela y de nicaragua ya que
como lo mencionaba el reciente
no iba a asistir y que enviaría en su
lugar al canciller marcelo ebrard si los
representantes de la habana de caracas y
de managua no asistían esta decisión de
eeuu responde a un anuncio que ya había
hecho previamente de que no tenía la
intención de invitar a estos tres países
por no cumplir con la carta
interamericana de la oea esta carta
interamericana es un instrumento de la
organización de estados américanos para
proteger las democracias del continente
y establece que los países que integran
la organización de estados américanos
deben respetar los derechos humanos y
llevar a cabo elecciones libres y justas
por esto esta decisión del presidente
mexicano de no asistir significa de
alguna manera un espaldarazo a nicolás
maduró a daniel ortega y a miguel díaz
canel de todas maneras el presidente
mexicano por supuesto no rompe
relaciones con eeuu que es su principal
socio comercial y como mencionaba envía
en su lugar al canciller marcelo ebrard
sin embargo esta ausencia también es un
golpe para las discusiones que se espera
tengan lugar a cabo aquí en esta cumbre
de las pues méxico es uno de los
principales actores en el tema
migratorio que se espera se ha incluido
en la declaración final de esta novena
cumbre de las américas y con la ausencia
y la representación del canciller
marcelo ahora se espera que estas
discusiones que tengan lugar hoy lleguen
a un objetivo concluyente